WHAT WE'VE SEEN SO FAR.
IT'S BEEN BILLED AS THE
FIRST-HAND ACCOUNT OF THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN HARRY AND
MEGHAN.
THE FIRST THREE EPISODES DROPPED
IN THE EARLY HOURS OF THIS
MORNING AND RETURNED TO FAMILIAR
THEMES.
>> THAT PRESS PACK OF ROYAL
CORRESPONDENTS IS EXTENDED PR
ARM OF THE ROYAL FAMILY.
>> Reporter: HARRY COMPARING
MEGHAN'S EXPERIENCE TO THAT OF
HIS MOTHER, DIANA'S.
HE FEARED SHE WOULD BE DRIVEN
AWAY BY THE MEDIA HARASSMENT.
>> AS FAR AS THE FAMILY WAS
CONCERNED EVERYTHING SHE WAS PUT
THERE THEY WERE PUT THROUGH AS
WELL SO IT'S A RITE OF PASSAGE.
BUT MY WIFE HAD TO GO THROUGH
THAT SO WHY SHOULD YOUR
GIRLFRIEND BE TREATED
DIFFERENTLY?
WHY SHOULD YOU GET SPECIAL
TREATMENT?
WHY SHOULD YOU BE PROTECTED?
I SAID THE DIFFERENCE IS THE
RACE ELEMENT.
>> Reporter: ULTIMATELY HARRY
SAID HE HAD TO LEAVE THE UK TO
PROTECT HIS FAMILY.
>> I UNDERSTAND THERE WILL BE
PEOPLE WHO DISAGREE WITH WHAT
I'VE DONE AND HOW I'VE DONE IT
BUT I KNEW I HAD TO DO
EVERYTHING I COULD TO PROTECT MY
FAMILY, ESPECIALLY AFTER WHAT
HAPPENED TO MY MUM.
>> THAT'S YOUR GRANDMA DIANA.
>> I DIDN'T WANT HISTORY TO
REPEAT ITSELF.
>> Reporter: WE HEARD FROM
MEGHAN'S MOTHER FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
>> I REMEMBER WHEN I FIRST MET
HIM, TOO.
HE WAS JUST LIKE 6'1", HANDSOME
MAN WITH RED HAIR.
REALLY GREAT MANNERS.
>> Reporter: HARRY SAYS WHEN HE
INTRODUCED MEGHAN TO HIS FAMILY,
THEY DIDN'T THINK THE
RELATIONSHIP WOULD LAST.
>> THE ACTRESS THING WAS THE
BIGGEST PROBLEM, FUNNY ENOUGH.
THERE'S A BIG IDEA OF WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE FROM THE UK
STANDPOINT.
HOLLYWOOD AND THERE'S THIS EASY
FOR THEM TO TYPECAST THAT.
>> Reporter: THE COUPLE SAY THEY
FELT UNPROTECTED BY THE PALACE
AGAINST A BARRAGE OF MEDIA
ATTACKS.
THE PALACE IS YET TO COMMENT.
THEY ARE QUITE A DIVISIVE COUPLE
IF YOU'RE A MEGHAN FAN OR HARRY
FAN, THERE'S A HUGE AMOUNT
YOU'LL FIND FASCINATING.
IF YOU'RE NOT, PERHAPS YOU'RE
NOT EVEN WATCHING IT.
>> MAX FOSTER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THAT'S THE MOST I'VE SEEN OF IT
BECAUSE IT DROPPED WHEN WE WERE
COMING INTO WORK.
>> WE HAVE TO GET SOME SLEEP
SOMETIME.
>> WE HAD TO SLEEP, TOO.
>>> DON, READ IT.
>> THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
>> YOU NEED ME TO STEP IN?
>> BIANCA JOINS US FROM
BUCKINGHAM PALACE AND HERE IN
NEW YORK IS --
>> TRISH GODARD, AND AARON
VANDERHOOF.
>> GOOD MORNING, APPRECIATE YOU
FOR JOINING US.
CAN WE GO TO BUCKINGHAM PALACE,
BECAUSE BIANCA IS AT BUCKINGHAM
PALACE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I WANT TO PICK UP ON SOMETHING
QUICKLY THAT MAX SAID, THERE'S A
DISCREPANCY ABOUT THE PALACE
BEING ASKED TO COMMENT AND THEN
SAYING WELL, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
COMMENT.
CAN YOU CLARIFY FOR US?
>> Reporter: I'M AFRAID I CAN'T.
BECAUSE NOBODY HAS BETTER ROYAL
SOURCES THAN MAX FOSTER HE'S IN
THE DOCUMENTARY AS WELL HIMSELF
SAYING SOMETHING IN PRAISE OF
MEGHAN IN THE MIDDLE OF EPISODE
2.
BUT IT HIGHLIGHTS HOW THIS CAN
BEGIN TO BE DIVISIVE AS IT GETS
DISSECTED AND WE GET A RESPONSE
FROM THE PALACE IF WE DO.
AS MAX ELUDED TO YOU GET A SENSE
WATCHING IT THAT IT'S BUILDING
UP TO A CRESCENDO.
THE FIRST THREE EPISODES OUT
THEIR LOVE STORY, WHICH IS
TOUCHING IN PART, AND THE EARLY
STAGES OF THE ENGAGEMENT AND
MEGHAN'S EARLY RECEPTION HERE IN
THE UNITED KINGDOM.
THE SECOND HALF IS WHY THEY HAD
TO LEAVE, WHY THEY FELT IT
WASN'T SAFE FOR THE FAMILY AND
COULDN'T LIVE IN THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES ANY LONGER.
WHAT STRUCK ME IS THE INTIMACY.
SCENES MEGHAN MARKLE IS IN HER
BATHROBE, IN A TUR BIN,
RECORDING HERSELF AND HOW SHE'S
FEELING.
THEY TALK ABOUT THEIR FIRST
DATE, THEIR FIRST KISS, SHARING
A TENT TOGETHER.
IT'S AN INSIGHT WE NEVER HAD
INTO FIGURES IN THE ROYAL FAMILY
BEFORE.
IT ALSO WORKS ON NUMEROUS
LEVELS, CLEARLY THE FAMILY
LEVEL, THE IMPACT THIS WILL HAVE
ON THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
PRINCE HARRY AND HIS BROTHER,
MEGHAN AND THE REST OF THE ROYAL
FAMILY AND THE SITUATION FOR
THEIR CHILDREN BUT ALSO ON A
ROIL AND NATIONAL LEVEL BECAUSE
THERE'S REFERENCES TO BRITAIN'S
HISTORY OF SLAVERY AND WHAT THAT
PLAYS IN THE DISCOURSE AND ALSO
THAT BREXIT WAS GOING ON,
SUGGESTING THAT MAY HAVE ADDED
TO THE DISCOURSE AROUND HER RACE
AND THE RESENTMENT OF SOMEBODY
IN HER BACKGROUND MARRYING INTO
THE ROYAL FAMILY.
IT'S A LOOK AT THIS AND THEIR
LIFE, SOME PEOPLE MAY HAVE SAID
WE'VE SEEN ENOUGH THERE'S BEEN
SO MUCH ABOUT THIS AND IT'S
OVERSATURATED.
I WONDER HOW DIFFERENTLY IT'S
VIEWED IN THE UNITED STATES
VERSUS HOW IT'S VIEWED --
>> IN THE UK.
>> IN THE UK BY BRITISH MEDIA.
THE TWO DIFFERENT APPROACHES
WE'VE SEEN TO HOW CANDIDLY THEY
SPEAK.
>> I THINK THAT THE UK IS GOING
TO FIND IT MORE DIFFICULT
BECAUSE THIS IS VERY HOLLYWOOD.
IT'S VERY PRODUCED AND WHAT HAVE
YOU.
BRITISH DOCUMENTARIES TEND TO BE
A LOT MORE RAW.
BUT I ACTUALLY LIKED IT.
I ACTUALLY DON'T SEE ANYTHING
WRONG.
I DON'T SEE -- YOU KNOW,
YESTERDAY I WAS ASKED DO YOU
THINK THE ROYAL FAMILY WILL BE
NERVOUS ABOUT THIS?
I THINK THE BRITISH MEDIA WILL
BE MORE NERVOUS.
>> WHY?
>> MORE CRITICAL.
>> MORE CRITICAL, MORE NERVOUS.
I THOUGHT THAT BECAUSE OF THE
BUILDUP.
THE BUILD UP AND IN THAT FIRST
EPISODE YOU SEE A MENTION OF
THAT ALMOST STRAIGHT OUT OF
COMPTON, WHICH IS ONE OF THE
FIRST HEADLINES THAT ONE OF THE
NEWSPAPERS CAME OUT WITH AND
THAT NEWSPAPER HAS BEEN
RELENTLESSLY ATTACKING.
AND AS WE KNOW THERE'S A LAWSUIT
AGAINST THAT NEWSPAPER FROM
SEVERAL HIGH PROFILE PEOPLE,
INCLUDING HARRY.
>> IT EXPOSES THEM IS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING?
>> YEAH.
I THINK IT EXPOSES THEM, LEAKS
THEM BACK TO THE DAYS OF DIANA,
DAYS OF TABLOIDS LIKE THE DAILY
MIRROR WHEN THEY WERE PHONE
TAPPING, I HAVE TO SAY THEY
REFUTED THAT BUT THERE'S STILL A
LAWSUIT THERE.
SO I THINK THE BRITISH MEDIA
WILL SEE IT MORE OF AN ATTACK
THAN THE ROYAL FAMILY WOULD.
>> LET'S LISTEN TO MORE OF THIS.
THIS IS MEGHAN TALKING ABOUT
SORT OF -- IT'S NOT COMFORTABLE
TO DO THIS BUT WHY THEY FELT
THEY HAD TO DO THIS.
HERE SHE IS.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO SAY IT'S
COMFORTABLE, BUT WHEN PEOPLE SAY
YOU HAVEN'T GOTTEN ANY SENSE OF
WHO YOU ARE FOR SO LONG.
IT'S NICE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LET PEOPLE HAVE
MORE OF A GLIMPSE INTO WHAT'S
HAPPENED AND WHO WE ARE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, I THINK WATCHING --
HAVING WATCHED ALL THREE
EPISODES NOW, I THINK YOU SEE
WHAT REALLY WAS MOTIVATING
MEGHAN TO DO THIS IN HER
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE MARKLE
FAMILY.
YOU REALIZE YOU HAVE HEARD FIVE
OF MEGHAN'S ANONYMOUS FRIENDS
TALK ABOUT THEIR RELATIONSHIP,
YOU HEARD MEGHAN'S LAWYERS TALK
ABOUT HER RELATIONSHIP WITH HER
DAD BUT YOU NEVER HEARD HER TALK
ABOUT IT.
YOU CAN TELL THERE'S A SENSE SHE
STARTED TO RESENT HOW MUCH THEY
WERE TELLING HER TO DEAL WITH
HER OWN FAMILY AND NOT ABOUT
OPTICS AND NOT ABOUT THE FACT
SHE HAD A DIFFICULT CHILDHOOD
GROWING UP, HER PARENTS DIVORCED
WHEN SHE WAS YOUNG AND I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF TRAUMA AROUND
THAT FOR HER AND THIS IS HER
TAKING THE OPPORTUNITY TO CLEAR
IT UP.
THE FIRST THREE EPISODES, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN NEXT BUT THE FIRST TH